hi welcome to my talk I hope you had a
great lunch yeah so my talk is how not
to read a room creating a socially
awkward wearable and I'm gonna start
with the disclaimer that yes like this
is my talk I'm going to spend the next
30 minutes or so just talking about my
necklace so if you're not prepared for
that feel free to leave and I'm going to
talk about my necklace because it's
using a lot of tech to respond to people
around me it's it's loaded with tech so
here's here's how it's basically working
so I have a camera around my neck on
this choker that's taking a picture and
this camera is attached to a Raspberry
Pi down on this girdle on my waist and
the PI is running nodejs tensorflow J is
in an image recognition model and the
machine learning model on the PI
determines how many people it sees and
then ascends that info to an Adreno and
the Adreno is attached to all these LEDs
and is controlling the liza-lu necklace
and when it gets the message from the pi
is updating the colors and patterns of
the LEDs based on preset parameters that
I have to tell that how it should
respond if you don't know who I am
I'm Stefanie I'm a web developer and I
live in Berlin and I'm originally from
Alabama actually but I live in Berlin
and I'm a front-end web engineer on
Microsoft to do and I'm mainly for my
day job I'm doing react really focused
on accessibility and HTML and CSS yeah
and so I started making wearables a few
years ago and I started maybe making
lighted clothing just because I thought
it was beautiful I kind of started
making them before I thought about the
implication
of me actually having to wear them so
they're really beautiful to me but
they're also kind of a burden for me I
love them but it's really hard for me to
deal a lot with the attention that they
draw and I've tried to channel that
anxiety from wearing them into
fascination and cultivate like this
fascination and excitement around it and
use them in some ways to confront the my
discomfort of the attention that they
draw and I wanted to show you a couple
of like where I started from making - so
I didn't start making something like
this this is quite complicated so the
first project ever beiie was this
fiber-optic dress I was going to a
festival and I thought this was just
kind of thinking that you did at
festivals I don't know I don't get out
much so I don't know so I copied in an
Instructables tutorial I bought this is
a fiber-optic way of rave whip so it's
just like a like I think 200 strands of
fiber optics attached to a flashlight
and it has preset patterns on the
flashlight you just click a button to
change it so I just followed it exactly
my mom sewed this dress for me and then
I sewed all the LEDs
sorry not only used all the strands of
fiber optics on it
there was no programming no soldering
that and when I wore it for the first
time I felt extremely awkward but I got
lots of compliments and people would
just like liked interacting and had a
lot of questions about it and it gave me
a bit of a self-esteem boost and so that
kind of is part of the motivation I keep
going because I don't know people I like
compliments I just I liked it but I wish
they could have been more alive and
interactive it was more like I just set
the program on it and just wore it and
there was there was no like
responsiveness to it so this is the next
project I made
and I this was the project on me last
year and I gave a talk about this award
at several conferences I've linked to my
conference talk at Jas confit you
I thought link if you want to check it
out but this in this project I so by
this time I had been coding for a bit
longer
and I felt like I could actually try to
code something on hardware and actually
put my skills to work in the hardware
piece so I wanted to explore the
reactions of people when they realized
that the lies could be changed with the
web app so I made this these pieces and
then I also had a web app that I built
and react that you could go to and click
colors and patterns and send it to my
outfit so anyone on the web could change
the colors and patterns and it was a lot
of coding a react app and then on the
backend I was using nodejs MQTT
messaging protocol and a jury knows and
it was a ton of soldering it was a lot
of work but people really liked it but
with having a web app I was stuck having
to always have my phone and have to
tether Wi-Fi off of it to have the
connection and in this piece I really
purposely wanted to explore creating a
temporary experience that create a
viewer with directly to the art piece
for a brief moment like kind of blurring
the line of if I'm the artist because I
made the piece or if they're the artist
because they're actually changing and
influencing how it looked when I wore it
so it was an interesting direction to go
but it was kind of a way not the way I
really wanted to continue exploring I
really wanted to take away the need for
direct interaction by others and I
wanted the wearable to focus more on me
and what I was experiencing then just be
influenced by other people so the next
project this is the last project I made
before this I made this speech to image
necklace
and I used to live in Amsterdam last
year and my colleague and I we ran a
stupid hackathon and this is like the
project updated for the stupid hackathon
you don't know what a stupid hackathon
is you should like check this out or
have your own because everyone just
comes is so not serious everyone just
comes and makes the most ridiculous app
they can think of and it's just a lot of
fun and low pressure situation but
anyway I made this necklace and it was
show an accompanying images to what I
was saying so it doesn't have sound what
I have a caption so I'm saying I like
turtles and then it's showing the meme
of a kid dressed up as a zombie that
said I like turtles so it found that so
I made this necklace so when I was
speaking to someone it was show images
of what I was saying and that they would
in an attempt that they would find me
interesting and continue engaging
conversation with me this was like just
my exploration here so what it is is a
Raspberry Pi 3d with a touch screen
attached and a microphone and I have an
ojs server running and sending audio
from what I'm saying to the Google
speech recognition cloud API and then
sending those keywords to the to a
Google Custom Search API and doing it MS
search and then sitting that back so it
was responsive to the environment but
it's still needed Wi-Fi which I think of
as a negative and interestingly enough
since I'm going to talk about for the
rest of talk about machine learning in
this project I want to point out that I
on eclis didn't really realize I was
using machine learning here I until I
really looked back to work on this talk
because I feel like machine learning is
a bit pervasive and I used it here and I
really just thought I was using api's
and I was just sending a request and
getting back
once they actually have built something
with machine learning before and didn't
really realize it yes so for the rest of
the talk I'm going to talk about this
necklace and I wanted to take the things
from those other projects and go in a
different direction so I wanted it to be
responsive to people around me but in a
way that actually would decrease my sari
that increases my discomfort until I
conform to social norms so I wanted it
to be obnoxious flashy attention-getting
when I was keeping to myself and it
would only calm down and eventually turn
off when I force myself to be sociable
and surround myself with other people
there's no app to control this is just
using machine learning and a camera so
it's yeah I senses how many people
around me and responds accordingly two
parameters I've set and it may seem like
I'm purposely trying to attract people
with the lights but to me I see is less
about that it's more about me wanting to
get rid of the lights as soon as
possible and that forcing me to be
sociable so and I feel like showing you
all these projects in this progression
of my work is really a convincing reason
all the convincing reasons that you
would need to know why I made this
project but I've got a LED mislead you a
bit because there really was a defining
moment earlier this year when I decided
to make this so like I said before I
worked at Microsoft and I started this
job almost a year ago and when I started
it was my first job at like big mega
tech Corp and I felt very insecure with
my skills everyone else has CS computer
science degrees I am a non-traditional
coder I'm a career changer later in life
changer and after I started at this job
folks started a machine learning study
group and they were doing a big online
MOOC course online and everyone from the
first study group everyone was learning
so fast and I was falling behind from
the first study group and I really
wanted to prove to mainly to myself that
you could learn all these concepts but I
could do it in my own style in the own
my own way of learning and for me that
meant I wanted to create a physical use
case for machine learning that was
relevant to me and my interest and so
the real reason I made this is because I
couldn't keep up with a machine learning
course at work and I wanted to prove
myself to everyone and to myself so I
started looking at other alternative
like videos and ways of learning and
there was true that really helps me so
the first one is this machine learning
for artists course created by Jean Pogan
he's a gives a lot of lectures but he's
a he teaches at NYU and this really
opens in my eyes my eyes to what artists
and non-traditional technologists are
doing with machine learning for example
this is using facial expressions to play
Tetris and it just there's just watching
the videos there's just so many projects
like this and it really opened up to my
eyes until how you could creatively
integrate a machine learning into a
wearable - this a new wearable project
and the second learning resource that
really helped me is coding train with
Dan Shipman and I mean I learned I
watched a lot of his videos on getting
started with tensorflow j/s and honestly
the nicest thing about his videos like
you do learn a lot is that he's so
humble and he's like I don't know what
I'm doing with tensorflow genius but
let's try this
and he shows himself like learning and
felling as as go so that it kind of
helps boost my confidence to keep going
on this project so yeah so I was
learning about since our foliage is and
I could have made things a lot easier
for me since I'm going to be using
hardware by not using tensorflow Jas and
not using javascript and doing this all
in Python but like if you were here
earlier for terrace talk like if you can
do it in JavaScript it'll probably be
done in JavaScript and I'm a JavaScript
engineers so and this no one had really
done like tensorflow json hardware on a
pie yet so I kind of wanted to be one of
the first so I want to do all the
machine learning in JavaScript and if
you're not a familiar with since with
Fuji is it's just a library for training
and running machine learning models in
the and it's mainly geared at the
browser not the backend so since it was
geared more towards the browser there's
really two things that I wasn't sure of
from the beginning and this that I
started with because I had they were the
unknowns that I had to figure out to
finish my project is I needed to get the
machine learning model running a node
and and instead of in the browser and to
I wasn't even sure if sure if I could
run tensorflow j/s and node on a PI yet
so I started with this machine learning
model tiny yellow it stands for you only
look once and I chose this one because
it's one of the fastest for in browser
image detection on like kind of like
mid-level equipment it can do it in like
800 milliseconds which is pretty fast it
just has a really it doesn't have like a
full image library is like the Yola
model so it's just it had people unless
I was only really concerned with people
so this is what I decided to use and was
already trained so I wouldn't have to do
any of that and so I needed to convert
this to work not in a browser in node
and to do this it was
just a lot of minor code changes like
things if you were just converting
something to run to note anyway so I had
to use a different sensor flow GS
packaged they have one built for node as
the head to store the models locally
instead of on the web
I had to modify like import-export
statements to like require statements
and I couldn't then this model they were
using the webcam like API is this media
devices getusermedia API I can't use
that since this browser base so I had to
convert it to use image load image files
and use that instead of just using like
a webcam API yeah and I'm not going to
show like a lot of code snippets are in
this talk because it's so specific to
this project but I have links to like
all my that there will be some code but
that there are like links to all my
github repos and stuff if you want to
check it out so I got the model running
in node so the next I needed to get
tenser fudge is working on Raspberry Pi
and when I started this project back in
the end of January I got really lucky
that the tensorflow j/s team had just
started working on this like a few days
before so they had made a change
it wasn't merged into the release yet
but they had the code in place basically
that you had to check for like the
operating system and if they would
support using the architecture that the
PI uses so I had to since it was there
but it wasn't in the build I had to like
figure out how to get it running locally
on my PI so I just had to build it using
like a yawl library to build it but I
got it working I was pretty proud of
that because I had never tried to do
that before and there's I have a
disclaimer that I'm using like the older
pretty like eight months old version of
tensorflow ejs like so the current
release is one point two point eight and
they're also pretty
prepping release candidate 2.0 right now
but i don't care i did this months ago
and honestly i don't want to touch it
and mess it up that's one reason and
yeah if it works like i mean this is
just my own personal project like i
don't feel pressure to like upgrade
things like if it works and it's just
sitting on me and not on the web and
there's no real vulnerabilities like it
just runs so just a disclaimer if you
want to try to get this running
yourself either will be some differences
from my code um yeah so this is like a
picture I took that you can actually see
when the first pictures I took so and it
actually recognized that I had a dog and
me and the it was probably a dog and
probably a person in the picture and
yeah this was just like really exciting
to me it was probably one of the first
projects running tensorflow jas and a
model on a PI yeah so the next thing I
since I had those two big things that I
was worried about accomplished the next
I needed to create this necklace and I
as a maker
I see shiny new hardware and stuff all
the time and I buy stuff all the time
it's a curse but I had these things
called blinky tiles it's this kit for
people can like learn how to solder you
can make these like octahedral balls and
it comes with just a microcontroller
with it that's preset with programs so I
wanted to use that and I actually had
tried to make a wearable with it before
just using their controller that comes
with it and I made this wearable but
when I moved to Berlin for my job it got
completely destroyed so I
kind of when I just to like harvest all
these parts since I thought when I made
something before it was quite beautiful
and just reuse this but I wanted to use
my own microcontroller so then I could
actually hook it up with a pie and
control everything and and luckily like
there is a library for controlling
blinky tall's with an Adreno I guess
like one take home of this talk is like
I'm really glad that like you can find
libraries and use them and you should
try to do that and just you can you
don't always have to reinvent the wheel
you can like build off of the work of
others and do it do things that they
weren't even expect you to do with their
libraries so yeah that was Allah so I
knew that they it could be controlled
with another tree now so I just to just
I before I completely got my wearable I
just tested it and I was able to use a
teensy 3.2 Adreno board and plug it in
and I could actually control it to flash
the lights back and forth so then I
started laying out and trying to design
the wearable and I yeah I thought I
wanted to do something like over over
the shoulder but then I decided more on
like a statement necklace type design
and as you can see how the photo on the
right this is how it ended up
and I would solder everything I have a
mannequin and I'd soldered everything
like this just on a man I can just
meticulously cutting wires and soldering
directly on my mannequin to make sure I
have like the best like fit so yeah I
created I wired and soldered that then I
needed to figure out actually how to get
data from the PI to the Adreno and the
lights of the wearable so I needed to
find a way to have communication between
the Raspberry Pi and the Drina
and for this I wanted to use I didn't
want to rely on anything like wireless
base like no Bluetooth no Wi-Fi I wanted
to
Oh No
[Music]
okay maybe like since enough people I
don't know this is very scary to do with
the wear it wearable yeah so I wanted to
just kind of just hardwire everything so
it would be more robust for me that I
would not possibly could fail from
wiring but it wouldn't fail from the
dropping a signal somewhere so I decided
to use serial ports and on the PI they
have one for receipt they have a pin
that's receiving and one for sending so
I could just in on the Drina they have
the same thing so I could just like
hardwired like a wire basically between
them just to send from one to the other
and I really struggled with this like
there's a lot of documentation for the
Raspberry Pi 3 B on setting up serial
communication but there was like a lot
of caveats to this and I really got
stumped for a couple weeks trying to
figure this out because I wanted to do
this thing called a loopback just to see
if on the Raspberry Pi was working it's
just where you connect from the sending
to the receiving and it just sends a
message back and forth to itself and I I
couldn't get it working and I send out
desperate retweets on the internet
trying to find get somehow but I did
eventually get it working and I was very
happy to see this this is like the
loopback console I could see that it was
sending something back and forth and
this is like all the config I had to set
up to just to get the serial working on
the Raspberry Pi 3 I found some like
really obscure blog post there was just
a lot of things that like on boot I
needed to like disabled and
yeah setup so I just wasn't expecting
that's a big difficult but sometimes
like simple things are difficult I guess
at this point I had built my wearable
and I had my PI and I wanted hooked them
up together but I was having some
serious issues on both so the first one
as you can see I was having some power
issues on the Raspberry Pi it is not
supposed to be strobe blitz spike
seizure interesting flashing and this
felts like a bill I knew it was some
kind of power issues and I know like the
the blinky tiles they run on five volts
and the teensy was like 3.3 volts but it
was 5 volt tolerant it just is a little
bit like I love hardware but it's still
kind of like a black box it to me I'm
just discovering things as I go so it
was a little bit out of my abilities at
the time to really spend a lot of time
debugging this so I just switched boards
and I like I said I buy a lot of stuff
for making so I had these this mini
Metro lying around for another project
that I never made I used a different
board for it and I switch switched it
and I got really lucky that because I
was suspecting it was like 5 volts 3
volts issues in the mini Metro has a 5
volt output so that matched the blinky
tiles better and it actually solves my
problem and luckily like I didn't even
realize it at the time but the library I
was using for the jury no blinky lights
communication like this is one of the
few boards that what the architecture
will work for this so I just kind of
learned things like after the fact by
just by luck and that's like a happy
instance because that doesn't happen a
lot the other big problem was my
Raspberry Pi was crashing it was a had a
huge memory leak
and after about an hour running it was
full and the swap memory was getting
full and I was just monitoring on H talk
like remotely to see this and I was
trying to debug this and all I saw us
all that was that a node app was running
and I looked through my code like what I
had no idea like it didn't seem like
there was like any memory leak in my
code and then the reason was if you
remember this project speech the image
necklace project I was using the same Pi
in the same SD card and this was
actually still booting up on startup
because I was using like p.m. to to like
booted up and start up and run node and
turns out that a project has a memory
leak and so that's why I was really hard
to debug because I just saw that was
like this node app called a tas run and
that's like what i names both of them
and yeah so yeah it turned out that this
was still running and i had a memory
late but i fixed it and this does not
have a memory link i'm really limited
just by the size of battery that i use
with this to run this now so after our
fixing those bugs i could give that
contract to what I originally was like
in the process of doing which was
sending data from the PI to the lights
and so I had to ask myself a question
how do I I'm going to use serial port
but how do I want to send the data and
being a front-end JavaScript developer I
said I use JSON everywhere else I'll use
JSON here and it turns out JSON on
Adreno is a thing there's a there's a
library and I got it working this is the
code from this is a code on the PI oh
yeah sorry on the adrene oh so I can
just use this library and this
running if you're not familiar with like
Adreno it has like s two main programs
running there's a setup it's start when
it starts and then there's a loop and
you basically put anything you want to
be called in the loop and it's just
constantly running over and over so
whenever we get a message or we create
this JavaScript structure and then it
gave parsall and get the data from it
and it worked but it was it turned out
to be a really bad decision and it
turned out to be a really bad decision
because whenever this loop was running
when it actually received data the light
would pause to process it Audrina is
like single-threaded and it has very I
mean it's like tiny it has very limited
resources so this was just like - like
memory intensive for really just getting
a number from the PI to process it so I
took a step back and thought about like
not what I know but what is actually
good for hardware not my web knowledge
of JSON and I switched to using just
bytes and I could just use three bytes
so this is code from the note out just a
snippet of what I changed so I just
changed it so I just create a buffer
with three bytes and then I have like
one byte at the beginning and one at the
end just so the Drina will look for
those and all the signals that it gets
over serial and then no one is getting a
message and then it just gets the I just
in the number because I just need one
byte because it's gonna all that the
tiny yellow can handle the time is like
20 objects to recognize so it would
never be over like a byte size when it's
only could be up to 20 so I switched to
that
yeah for like the rest of my work it was
really just working and like C++ Adreno
code to build the lights and yeah I just
read a bunch of C programs and I'm not
gonna show you the light programs but
I'll show you just kind of so you can
understand kind of what's happening on
the necklace is I'm basically once it
gets the message of how many people
there are it can switch program so it
sets a program based on on that and what
I have going on is this like a lot more
chaotic and energetic at the beginning
and then as it gets up to I think six
people is when it'll finally shut down
because tiny yellow can do up to 20
image recognized but the thought of 20
people around me for to turn off was
terrifying
so I did what I was comfortable with I
thought like six people is like a good
amount of people to have around me so it
gets a message gets the people count and
updates the program um and you can see
all like C codes on this link if you
want to check that out and I had all
been testing this on my mannequin and
not on me so when I finally put it on me
there was problems so I was having some
bad connections and I was shorting and
the fit I originally thought I would
just wear like a fanny pack and put
everything in but everything is like way
too big for that so this is why I
decided to move to like this waist
cincher and sewing things on and it's
just like a lot better fit and if you're
doing wear a protocol project like
always wear track on your stuff like way
before and don't do what I did and then
there's like one bonus feature I added
in because sometimes frankly I just had
enough and I
handle anymore of like this at the
moment and I need a break so I wanted to
add in a way to turn off the lights
completely so what I did is I have here
I have a ring that I made with a button
and I can long press it and turn it off
and I can long press it to turn back on
but the other thing is maybe I if I want
to switch the programs completely
meaning that when no one's around it's
calm and then there's more people around
it's really energetic I also put in that
I can do a short press and yeah it will
like basically flip like the program of
what's going on
turn it back oh okay
sometimes I get confused even like what
program I'm on myself
yeah so I that's the last thing I did it
I added it in and you can kind of see
these are like the the programs I wrote
and see for these button presses and
[Music]
yeah this was a really hard build and I
got demotivated a lot it took eight
months versus three months and that's
because I took some like month-long
breaks between some of these problems
that I was having like with like power
issues and things like it just didn't
work on it continuously and I always
could have done stuff differently but
this is what works for me and I hope
it's inspired you or in Picher curiosity
about wearables and machine learning and
I just want to say thank you and that I
love talking about non tech things like
I love luck it was talking about
techniques but I also love talking about
non tech things so for some conversation
starters so if you like fashion or now
art or dogs or boat
you feel free to come and talk to me
about any of these things or we can talk
about tech - I'm not doing a QA because
I just don't do Q&A s because I'm very
sensitive after with like the end of a
talk I did bring stickers if you want to
need queer J s or I have this like
little dog character I'm a little pink
dog on the computer I don't know I have
stickers up here you can find me I'll be
here both days so say hi let's chat and
that's it thank you
[Applause]